we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got CrossFit white-eyed surf set
cardio mission in boot camp it's your
body
this is fighting I'm Tyler and I'm a
disciple of more time
more time is basically what we call the
science of eight okay coming from from
Thailand where the predominant religion
is Buddhism it's very spiritual it's
very culturally based okay you learn how
to use all eight parts of your body or
your elbows your knees your shins your
feet by training in that style you also
get into the best physical shape that
you can possibly get this is so much
more passion involved in the training
and the techniques you're going to build
your muscles you're going to build your
flexibility you're going to become more
athletic you're going to have better
endurance you're gonna you're going to
master your own body get involved in
more time because it will change your
mind body and soul here's the mai tai 3
minute workout ok so this is going to be
my student 4 for our little beginning
intro to our 3 minute class so what
we're gonna work on do is we're gonna
work on the basics of how you would
stand how you would move your breathing
techniques and why it's important to do
to do such ok so what I want you to do
is put both feet together okay so we're
gonna take our right foot we're going to
turn out one degree out right and then I
want to separate that foot out a little
bit now I'm gonna go a little wide ok
now my hands down by my side I'm taking
my right hand to my chin and one left
hand out in front of me
ok now this is your basic stance yes so
you're not breathing when you punch you
forced me out okay so go ahead give me
150 very good very good we want to do
that keep your hands up a little higher
ok do it again perfect so now what we
can do is we can just add a knee strike
to that so we're gonna go left right
right now my hands gonna come back I'm
gonna bring my back knee a foot is
already [ __ ] I'm gonna bring my knee
right up the middle
so for cardio purposes we just go and
back to that position okay okay go ahead
though good now we go over some other
stuff close range strikes elbows okay
most effective when you got so you put
your hands up practice in the mirror now
so I would go to my elbow this would be
a cross elbow I'm gonna come up and
block with my face here bang and come
back cover the face snap the elbow good
do it again good so now we're gonna do
the same things up we're gonna add
another nice regular front knee is going
to come up one down and then to okay
give you 25 of those okay here we go so
front knee up go perfect now reset your
feet take your time let's one do it
again
good two more so tired you can hit me
all day pretty [ __ ] black sand
breathe how hard is that right now what
you can also do as soon as you get done
doing that that combination right just
simply go down hold the push-up position
go ahead drop in alright so here we go
right gonna hold your hands here right
you know that table go behind you one
down back up two down 6b7
put the eight nine come on oh this sucks
yeah drop down relax sit back on your
butt sit up chest back shoulders out if
you really get tough and put your hands
behind your head you breathe relax here
we go to recap our three minute workout
you're going to do 25 a jab cross
punches you're also gonna throw 25 inch
strikes on your throw 25 jab elbow so
left elbow across okay 25 mm strikes
left and then right 25 in a row okay
then you can do the one-minute push up
hold simply hold the push-up position
for one minute you can switch your hands
at the advanced version and you're done
you can have a 1 minute cooldown and
repeat this at least three times a week
to get the most benefit out of you
workout thanks for the from your weary
shading thank you very much yes this is
good stuff make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes
you